what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so I've been sitting here thinking about
how in the world I was gonna make this
video because I like shooting stuff from
the hip I like my videos to be more of
like a conversation then like a lecture
his lectures are kind of boring and I
didn't want the title to be super
spoilery so I just kind of went with
Doctor Strange the mid-credits scene
explained having said that if you need
to be told that this video is gonna have
spoilers then I don't know what to tell
you but this video is gonna have
spoilers so the mid-credits scene of
Doctor Strange is Thor and Loki showing
up to the house of Doctor Strange and
Thor asking where's Odin so we know that
somewhere Lon Lon Thor figured out that
Loki was masquerading as Odin so the
question is where is Owen now having
said that I want to preface this by
throwing word out there that the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is kind of teased at
the idea that Odin's dead like Anthony
Hopkins was like he's dead but it's
never been confirmed that he's dead so
it's just kind of like maybe but not
really having said that that's entirely
possible because in my mind
Odin is him one of three locations or
three places or states of existence
either he's in the Odin sleep he's dead
or and if Marvel's doing what I hope
they're doing I really hope this is this
happens because it'll be amazing if it
is he's with the sky father's now to
begin with the Odin asleep because the
sky father's opens up a whole nother
kettle of beans of the moral universe
regarding the sky father I'm sorry
guarding the Odin sleep for those of you
guys who don't know Odin's power is
what's called the Odin for so if you're
always curious like why is Odin so
powerful in what he can do it's
literally just called the odinforce it's
called the odinforce because Odin's in
possession of it if Thor had it which he
has it's just called the Thor force if
Loki had it it'd be called a Loki force
but the odinforce is basically the life
energy of Odin's two brothers when they
sacrifice their lives fighting Surtur
which we'll get to here in a second who
merged their energy with Odin and then
allowed Odin to defeat Serdar and
confine him to earth to what the center
of the world I think and from that point
going forward
Odin just had this massive amount of
energy the kicker with this is that the
odinforce doesn't really change in terms
of what it's capable of but despite the
fact that he's extremely long aged
despite the fact that he eats these
little mystical apples that prolong his
life
Odin is not inherently immortal a time
will come when Odin will just die of old
age that's just the way it is now it'll
be millennia before that happens with
but the time will come when that happens
I can't talk I'm Ron Burgundy
so with regards to the odinsleep
this is effectively Odin just recharging
himself now with the Marvel Comics this
is a plot device
you know because Odin is so powerful
whenever anybody shows up and tries to
attack Asgard Odin is like the power of
the odinforce compels you and they're
defeated and that's it and so by having
Odin fight some enemy like Galactus or
something like that
having him used up a massive amount of
his odinforce he goes to recharge that
energy in the Odin sleep now how long he
sleeps for is directly proportional to
how much energy he uses and so if you
were to fight against like Captain
America which would be an awesome fight
to see I'd love to see Captain America
vs Odin
but if you were to fight Captain America
and Steve Rogers were by some you know
miracle or another able to hold his own
the amount of energy or the amount of
sleep Odin would need to recharge from
that battle would be far less than if
you were to go against a cosmic entity
like eternity and so the more energy he
uses the longer he sleeps meaning that
if you were to fight you know someone
like eternity the Odin sleep may take
days or weeks sometimes even months or
years but it's just a way for Marvel to
remove him from the landscape so they
can have a legitimate you know situation
that shows up and challenges Asgard
leading to some event like Ragnarok or
something like that which will also talk
about that here in a second having said
that whenever Odin goes into the Odin
sleep
he's as easy to kill as any mortal the
caveat to this is he's also 100 percent
of where of what goes on around him so
he knows everything that's happening the
issue is that once he goes into the Odin
sleep he can't wake up prematurely he
has to sleep for the entire duration of
the Odin sleep now how that translates
in the movie the model hunter isn't sure
but in the comics has been kind of
fickle there have been a couple times
here and there where he's just woken up
from the Odin sleep prematurely but as
far as I'm aware whenever he goes into
the Odin sleep
barring some insane circumstance or
Marvel just kind of deviating away from
the status quo
he stays into the Odin sleep until he's
completely you know recharged and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we saw at the
end of for the dark world that Loki had
taken over the position of Odin by
basically shape-shifting to appear as
Odin and so something happened
Hannelore something happen off screen
and we didn't know what it was this
leads us into the second possibility of
Odin being dead now there are a couple
of ways in which this could have
happened it could have been that Loki
just killed him I could have been the
Loki was just like up time to die time
to kill Odin take his place no but that
wouldn't be interesting and be kind of
lackluster if we found out that Odin
just died off-screen and Loki had just
like stabbed him to death while he was
in the Odin sleep that'd be very
anti-climatic and in truth if you're
really disappointing and it would seem
to go against what Marvel does with
regards to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
was someone like Odin dies it would be
like this grandiose battle or something
crazy like that and so I don't think
that Odin is dead but it is possible and
the reason why it's also possible is
because of Surtur
for those of you guys who are familiar
with the idea of Ragnarok bear with me
for a second because a lot of people out
there are not so Ragnarok is like a
prophecy within the realm of Asgard it
is a time will come when Ragnarok will
happen there is the false Ragnarok and
there's the true Ragnarok the true
Ragnarok was what we saw in the last
days of Loki in the events leading up to
secret wars we're the ones who said
above in shadow returned and they said
no no that was never Ragnarok before the
false Ragnarok was what we saw with the
event Thor Ragnarok that took place
during Avengers disassembled and it
basically dealt with of the
quote-unquote death of Thor but
regardless of how the events transpire
there are a set of circumstances that
will lead to it so really Ragnarok is
more of like a series of events that
happen in sequence as opposed to one
huge climactic event the first is that
Odin is removed from the landscape and
that happened in Marvel Comics with
regards to the return of Surtur again he
had been confined to earth by Odin and
is a weird kind of mishmash of
situations but I'll run over all that
Ragnarok stuff once we get closer to
Thor 3 but the idea here was that Odin
had thought Serdar and had died in the
process and so because this Odin was
removed from the landscape what this did
is it set the stage for Loki to ally
himself with Cerner to ally himself with
all the enemies of Asgard and then
invade Asgard and kill off almost all
the Asgardians there were a handful that
survived here and there the Warriors 3
Thor so on and so forth but they were
all defeated and so the result was that
Thor actually went on this mystical
quest where he gained the runes of
Asgard and he was God Thor it was what
was it I own forced the war something
like that it was stupid he was like
multiversal powerful it was only for a
couple issues but it was crazy how
powerful he
was which I have a video on that deal
flying down in the description but the
fact remains here that Ragnarok follows
in that sequence now well the reason why
I say was a false Ragnarok is because we
learned in Marvel Comics that Ragnarok
is a repeating cycle up until that point
it was always just assumed that Ragnarok
was some event far off in the distance
and that would be Marvel killing off the
character of Thor Odinson but we learned
that there are these weird emic mattock
beams called the ones who sit above in
shadow who feed off the perpetual cycle
of Ragnarok and so right now in Marvel
Comics the version of Asgard that we've
seen is who knows how many iterations
there have been countless iterations
before that and the events always
transpire the same way now this is
likely due to the idea of you know earth
and different things like that but
nonetheless the video that I have in the
description will explain all that stuff
but it's entirely possible between these
two things that Odin was either killed
in his battle with Serdar or he was
killed by by Loki that that's that's
within the realm of reason my take on
this is that Odin is neither dead nor in
the Odin sleep instead he's meeting with
the sky fathers and the reason why I say
that is because of Thanos in Marvel
Comics the sky fathers are what are
called the second generation of gods or
also called the Council of godheads they
have a multitude of different names but
in on the planet Earth in Marvel Comics
you have like the Elder Gods which we
don't care about those are the first
gods that showed up that's like Gaia the
you know representation of Mother Earth
so on and so forth the second generation
of gods are basically the in Marvel
Comics representations of gods in the
modern day so Odin and Zeus and Vishnu
and so on and so forth gods that have
been historically worshiped by
civilizations here in the real world
throughout the history of our planet
this council of god has rarely ever
meets but when they do is because of a
massive crisis and Marvel Comics in 1991
when jim Starlin wrote the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline the Council of
godheads came together because of the
fact that Thanos had not only snapped
his fingers and wiped out half a life in
the universe but because he had also
destabilized the connection that these
pocket dimensions of Olympus and as
guard and someone have with earth and so
as a result it was more or less than Oh
screwing up the cosmic order of things
and because of this the council of
godheads came together and said we need
to do something to stop this the problem
or I guess not only a problem but the
other half of this coin was that Adam
warlock
who had long since been an enemy of
Thanos began the process of travelling
around the universe gathering up
whatever people he could that were left
from half of those people who were wiped
out you know from all existence and
rallied those individuals to fight
against Thanos so it was Adam warlock
who gathered what was left of the sky
fathers it was Adam warlock who gathered
this Silver Surfer Doctor Strange the
earth superheroes and it was Adam
warlock who gathered the cosmic entities
all of whom fought against Thanos and
all of whom were easily defeated they
were there it was man it was a sight to
behold if what we see in the movie in
the movie infinity war is anything like
what we saw in the comics you guys are
not prepared it's going to be not even
in Hell what you see a massacre like
what you will see in in the movies it'll
be God it'll be so amazing I'm so
excited I'm so hyped I'm sorry from so
excited people so anyway when it comes
to the sky fathers my thought is in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because of the
fact that Thanos is running around
capturing the Infinity stones because
don't forget and it's this is why I love
the Marvel Cinematic Universe because
it's so easy to do in light of age of
Ultron and Captain America Civil War and
what we'll probably see and Doctor
Strange and so on is very easy to forget
the Thanos is running around the
universe right now rounding up the
Infinity stones capturing up all the
different Infinity stones the Power
Stone and the mind stone the time stone
so on and so forth and so because of
this it's likely that Odin had realized
what was going on whether it was because
he monitored for when Thor had his
visions and saw the Infinity stones and
Odin said uh that's a problem we need to
bring the sky fathers together and go
check that out or whether it's because
Odin had just been monitoring everything
that was going on when he was in the
Odin sleep during Thor - when he was in
the Odin sleep and he'd been monitoring
everything that was going on and came to
the realization that Thanos was rounding
up the Infinity stones because remember
when Odin is in the Odin sleep he sees
everything in the universe everything
that's happening at that moment right
then and so if he realized that Thanos
was rounding up the Infinity stones then
it may have been that during the events
of Thor and during the events of Thor -
who said okay we'll deal with this
immediate threat and then we'll take off
will gather the sky fathers and figure
out what's going on with Thanos that's
my philosophy and the reason why I think
that is because it makes the Marvel
Cinematic Universe more cohesive but
again we don't really know what goes on
behind closed doors and as much as I'd
love to be
fly-on-the-wall of the meetings that are
taking place in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right now I can't I'm just a
guy making YouTube videos speculating on
what I think is happening and I think it
would create a more cohesive scenario
with Odin gathering sky fathers but we
also have to accept the fact that maybe
Anthony Hopkins just didn't want to play
oh de Namur and so Kevin Feige and those
guys just killed Odin off screen which
again would be kind of disappointing but
if you guys are new here to comics
explain and make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the robb
core and if you guys enjoyed this video
drop a like and I'm kind of curious let
me know down in the comments section
what's your off slot where do you guys
think
Odin is right now this very moment in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe do you
think he's alive do you think he's dead
are you like me and you hope he's
rounding up the sky fathers and they're
gonna be just one of the factions that
are gonna be fighting off against Thanos
while he has the Infinity Gauntlet I'm
curious because hmm some awesome things
are happening in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe what a time to be a comic book
fan it is all the movies and everything
from DC and Marvel and you got the
webseries coming from valiant it's a
great time to be a comic fan anyways
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]